mais il a quoi Bruce Willis il est
atteint de démence la démence fronto
temporale une démence c'est quand on
perd progressivement ses facultés
mentales du coup au bout d'un moment
tous les trucs qu'on fait tous les jours
bah on n'arrive plus à les faire c'est
le cerveau qui se dégrade on appelle ça
une dégénérescence dans le cas de la
démence frontaux temporale c'est le lobe
frontal et le lobe temporal qui sont
touchés en fait il se rétractent il
diminue il s'atrophie et dans ces deux
lobes il y a des zones qui gèrent
notamment le langage c'est comme ça que
ça a commencé pour Bruce Willis des
troubles du langage et au bout d'un
moment si le lobe frontal est vraiment
touché il peut aussi y avoir des
troubles du comportement en gros on a
plus trop de limites on dit des horreurs
et on est très débridé sexuellement et
puis comme c'est des zones qui gèrent
aussi notamment nos mouvements bah au
bout d'un moment non seulement on parle
plus mais en plus on se lève plus on
bouge plus c'est un type de démence qui
est assez rare on parle de 5000k en
France et ça touche le plus souvent des
hommes entre 45 et 65 ans force à eux et
force à Bruce Willis et à ses proches